la sonnerie retentit race cette année
dont près de 2000 établissements
scolaires de la région
les quatre départements accueilleront
dans leur salle de classe
pas loin de deux cent soixante sept
mille élèves
on comptera sont 43 mille écoliers du
côté des collèges et les lycées les
élèves seront un peu plus de 123 milles
cette rentrée scolaire ce sera aussi
celle des enseignants ils seront un peu
plus de 26 mille cinq cents à retourner
derrière le bureau au final le budget
consacré cette année à l'enseignement
par l'académie de dijon devrait être
d'un peu plus d'1 5 milliard d'euros
cette année encore le nombre d'élèves
par classe devrait être plus élevée dans
le second degré c'est-à-dire dans les
collèges et les lycées
l'an dernier on comptait par exemple 21
élèves par classe en moyenne dans les
écoles contre 24 dans les collèges et 28
en lycée général et technologique
il n'y a que dans les formations
professionnelles que le nombre d'élèves
est moins élevé on en compte dix huit en
moyenne par classe